ينهار بين عشيه وضحاها مخلفا وراءه مخاوف
لدى الزبائن الاثرياء والاسر الغنيه حول
كيفيه الحفاظ على اموالهم مع انتقال
الازمه الى اوروبا ايضا انهيار يمكن ان
تصاحبه انشقاقات في شبكه البنوك الاقليميه
وهنا يقول مستشار الثروه ان العديد من
العملاء يطرحون اسئله اساسيه حول كيفيه
ضمان اموالهم ومكان الاحتفاظ بها وفق
تقرير صادر عن شبكه
الازمه الماليه التي عصفت بالبنك الذي
يحتل المرتبه السابعه عشره في ترتيب
البنوك الامريكيه من حيث حجم الميزانيه
سيدفع العشرات من الاثرياء والاسر الغنيه
لتحويل المزيد من اموالهم من الارصده
النقديه في البنوك الى سندات الخزانه
ولتفادي الخساره يمكن ان يلجا الزبائن الى
استثمارات ذات عائد نقدي اعلى والتي لا
تكون عاده في الميزانيه للبنوك حيث سيتم
ضخ ارصدتهم النقديه في اسواق المال وغيرها
من الادوات القصيره كما سيحتفظ المستثمرون
اصحاب الثروات العاليه بملايين الدولارات
او حتى عشرات الملايين نقدا في حساباتهم
المصرفيه لتغطيه الفواتير والنفقات غير
المتوقعه اما بعض كبار المستثمرين فيرجح
ان يبتعدوا تماما عن البنوك بتحويل
اموالهم الى حسابات وصايه في شركات
الوساطه التي توفر معظم مزايا الحساب
المصرفي ازمه بنك السيليكون ورغم انها تعد
اكبر عمليه انهيار لبنك امريكي غير ان
السلطات الماليه الامريكيه تقول ان الامر
لن يؤدي الى اهتزاز في النظام المالي